[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So I'm here today
to talk about a technology
called Sign-In with Google.
My name is Laurence Moroney.
I'm a developer advocate.
I work out of our
Seattle offices.
And I focus mostly on Android
and on Google Play Services.
I've been doing a lot of work
with Identity, a lot of work
at Sign-In with Google
over the last few months,
and having a whole lot
of fun with the new APIs.
Has anybody tried out the new
Sign-In APIs yet, by the way?
OK, a few.
Cool.
Oh, actually one thing I forgot.
Before I go back, at the
bottom of this slide here,
you see I put a URL--
[? j.mp/offeedback. ?] If
you've any questions,
any feedback,
anything you'd like to
let us know about the API,
anything you want us to get
back to you on, or anything like
that, there's a simple
Google form on there.
You can do it
anonymously, or you
can give us your e-mail
address to give us
some feedback on that.
So you know, anything
along if I don't
have time for questions
at the end of the session,
or anything like that, I promise
we'll try and get back to you
with answers if you
fill in that form.
And if there's any really
difficult questions,
Paul here at this table will
be the one to answer them.
[CHUCKLES] He's glad they
turned the lights down.
Today, I want to really
talk about Sign-In
with Google and a particular
Google sign-in technology.
I have a blue button
on this screen here.
But we actually have a
branding guidelines document.
There's a link at
the end where if you
don't like the blue button,
we also have a white one.
There's also guidelines if you
need to customize the button,
if you don't like it, to
say Sign-In with Google.
And you want to localize it
to your own language, or maybe
something like Pig Latin, or
something along those lines,
then you can actually
customize that button.
There's lots of
resources on there
that will allow you to do that.
But before I begin talking
about Sign-In with Google,
I'm a bit of a stats geek.
And I love stats.
And I find there
are some great ways.
I know there are lies,
there are darned lies,
and there are statistics.
But I'm going to
use some statistics.
And I hope that you
find them interesting.
So the first of all
I'm going to start with
is that research has
found that 86% of users
do not like creating and
remembering new passwords
to interact with you.
What I find stunning about this
number is that it's not higher.
I mean I certainly hate
going to a new app,
or going to a new
site, and having
to do yet another signup.
And they probably
have different sets
of rules for what's
a valid password
and what isn't a valid password.
And I have to remember
all these things.
And then six months
later, the next time I
use that site or
app, again, I have
to remember what that
username and password was.
86% though, according
to research.
The next number is 54% of
users that, if you present them
with yet another signup,
will quit altogether.
So think about all
that time that you
spent building your app,
maybe making your app
work on multiple platforms,
like IOS, Android, Windows
Phone, all the
different platforms,
maybe working it with
a website as well,
and having a user's
identity with that--
All that time building that,
all that time marketing that,
all that effort that you get
for people to access your site,
or download your app and use it.
And more than half of
them will walk away
if you ask them to build yet
another username, or password,
or sign up with yet another
username or password.
So that's why technologies
like Sign-In with Google
are very important
to me, in particular,
because I don't want
to build apps like this
and have more than half
of my audience walk away.
And one more number is 92%.
92% will give up if they
don't remember the username
and password that they
signed up for on this site.
So if they try-- whoo, whoo.
I'm a little active
with my hands.
If they try to sign in, and then
they can remember the username
or password, and you provide
them with a forgotten link,
research has shown
that 92% of them
will just walk
away at this point.
So it's all very nice to be
able to give them that facility
to sign in, to recover a
forgotten password or identity.
But if only 8% of
them are using it,
that's a lot of wasted effort.
And a funny story
and a true story
is I'm doing grad studies at a
university that's not too far
from here that I won't name.
One of the best IT, one of the
best technology universities
in the world.
And I'm not a matriculated
student there.
So I come in through--
what they have
is a professional
development center.
And when I go to their
professional development center
to sign into that, I have to
give a username and a password.
The passwords on
this center has a set
of rules about what's a
valid password or not.
And their set of
rules for this one
is that you're not allowed
to have any capital letters.
And you're not allowed
to have any punctuation.
It's just lower case
letters and numerics.
So I come, and I sign in.
And I put in a
password for that.
And like most people,
all of my passwords
are kind of variations on a
theme, a very obscure theme
that only means something to me.
And so no uppercase
letters, no punctuation.
So I use lowercase letters
and a sequence of digits.
And then once I'm signed into
that, then to access everything
in the university like I'm a
real student-- so to access
e-mail, or to access my grades,
and all that kind of stuff--
they have a different
username and password.
And the password on that, you
have to have capital letters,
and you have to
have punctuation.
And as a result,
I'm like thoroughly
confused whenever I try
to sign in to this thing.
And almost every time I
have to reset my password
to be able to access my stuff.
I'm one of those 8% because
I have to access this stuff.
So I go through all
of that kind of thing.
And that to me is
really, really annoying.
And I'm sure it
would be to you, too.
So the idea, and part of our
goal with Sign-In with Google,
is to help you to use what
you know, to feel secure
that your credentials are
backed up by what we hope
and what we believe is a
world-class infrastructure.
And then if you're a developer,
so that you can offer this
to your users, too.
Instead of giving them
all of this friction,
instead of giving them
all of this hassle,
instead of different
sets of validation rules,
instead of having to remember
yet another username and yet
another password, that they can
just sign in with a Google ID
that they already
have, or hopefully
that they already have.
So some of the
features behind this.
So what we want to do is
we want to make it easy.
And we want to make
it familiar for users.
Most of your users will
probably have a Gmail address.
And most of your users are
familiar with signing in
for Gmail.
They probably know their
username and password
for Gmail.
And they can sign in to
your app or your site
as frictionlessly as
they can with Gmail.
We really want to
keep it that familiar.
And we want to keep it as
strong branding on that.
They know and they trust Gmail.
They sign into it
probably every day.
It's not a case of
a few months later,
they've forgotten
their password.
They're using this.
It's very easy.
It's very familiar for them.
It's also secure.
One thing I'm going to
talk about in a moment
is phishing and hacking.
And being me, there's
lots more stats.
So there's a lot more stats
on phishing and hacking.
But before I get to that, one
of the things about security
is that backend infrastructure,
the support mechanisms,
the overall machine behind
securing your user's identity,
if it's provided by Google,
it's at least as good as the one
that you would build yourself.
But I would argue it's
probably a lot better.
You want to focus on
building your application.
You want to focus on building
your site without thinking
about all of the time,
and effort, and cost
in building and maintaining
a world-class security
infrastructure.
Most of us aren't big enough
to be able to do that properly,
whereas if you're
using a Sign-In
with Google-type
technology, then
Google have done that for you.
So I think that's something
that it's very secure.
And it's also really
good for your users
as well as being
very good for you.
Then the next part of
this-- and it's part,
I'll be frank, that
we kind of failed on,
but we're really improving
on-- is making it easy to code.
If you've used
Sign-In with Google,
if you've tried to build
with Sign-In with Google,
up until about, I think it was
like September of this year,
the API was quite complex.
There'd be a case of you
would try to sign in.
And the way that you'd sign in
is by connecting a Google API
client.
But what would happen is the
first thing that the user would
see is a dialog asking
them, well, which
ID are you signing in with?
That would actually error
out the connection process.
And how you, as a
programmer, would handle that
is by handling that error.
Then once the user has selected
their ID, then in many cases,
the application would
ask them for some kind
of a permission, like
maybe accessing contents,
or if you're building
something, for example,
that uses Google Drive, the
user to give their permission
to access Google Drive.
That would also error out
the connection process.
And you'd have to handle
that as if it was an error.
And how you knew when
the user was signed in
was when your Google
API connected.
And you'd handled
all these errors.
And as a developer, to me, I
found that a little bit ugly.
A user picking their
name is not an error.
A user giving permission
is not an error.
And so we've really,
really improved the API.
I'm going to be showing off
some of the stuff in the API.
So I find it a lot easier.
I find it a lot quicker.
I find it a lot more
straightforward.
I hope you do, too.
And then the next thing
is to make it extensible.
It's all very well if
you've got a mobile device.
And you've got to sign-in
dialogue in the mobile device.
And the user has signed
into the device on that.
But then what?
Most of you likely have some
kind of backend service.
Most of you are probably
storing some kind of data
in that backend service that
has the user signing in.
Some of the customization of
the app comes from that data.
And maybe you want that
data to be secured, too.
Now, think about what can
happen with a middleman
attack between the
device and your server.
We'll talk about that a little
bit later in the presentation.
But one of the things
about Sign-In with Google
is it's not just
about your phone.
It's not just about your device.
It's also about being able
to secure backend services.
So first of all, I'd to talk
a little bit about the UX,
and some of the
things that we've
done to help you
focus on the user,
reduce some of this
friction, and improve the UX.
So my speaker notes, one
is really small here.
So I'm going to
just turn around.
So this is what it
used to look like.
So on the very left hand side,
you have your application.
And you've got a set
of sign-in buttons.
Like the top one is
Sign-In with Google.
The middle one is Facebook.
The bottom one, I
think, is Yahoo.
So the user would pick
Sign-In with Google.
What would happen?
Well, first of all they
would get a request asking,
can this access their contacts?
Can this access your contacts?
Why, when signing
into this application,
should this application
access my contacts?
And there's a rule
of thumb that I
like to follow that every time
you give the user a choice that
really isn't
relevant to what they
want to do at this moment in
time, you lose 90% of them.
And to me, this is
a great case where
you could lose 90% of them.
So you then select that
when the user is very nice.
And they say, OK, yes I will.
And then they get this, oh,
you got to give me permission.
And then they say OK to that.
And then it's like OK, once
they've given permission,
now I have to ask for
the contacts again.
Once they give that
permission, now finally,
oh, what account do you
want to sign in with?
This phone only has
one account on it,
but yet you need to tell
me the account that you're
going to sign in with.
So that's what?
That's the fifth from the left.
So once they pick that one, and
they sign in, now guess what?
This user didn't have
a Google+ profile.
Oh, we can't continue.
We need to fill out
a Google+ profile.
So they would have to fill
out a Google+ profile.
They create that, submit,
and then finally, guess what?
It's asking them for
their basic info,
including the list
of their contacts.
And then they say, OK to that.
They allow it.
And then finally, they're
signed into the application.
There's a lot of friction here.
We understand this.
So we've tried to improve it.
And we fixed it.
So now it looks like this.
So now we say, OK,
let's get started.
Let's sign in with Google.
The first thing
is, well, we just
need to know which
account on your phone
you're signing in with.
In this case, I'm going
to pick the account.
And then in most cases,
I'm straight into the app.
Sometimes, there
will be another step
between the second
and third of these,
and that's if the user has
to give specific permissions
to access something.
I like to use Google
Drive as an example.
So if you're building
an application that
accesses their stuff
on Google Drive,
then they would have a third
step in between the middle one
and the one on the right here.
But that's how
frictionless it has become.
We're really, really
proud of this.
We shipped this in the last
version of Google Play Services
back in September-ish.
And we think it will make it
a lot easier for your users
to be able to sign in, and to be
able to feel secure in signing
in without all these
dialogues asking them
for stuff-- sometimes
stuff that may not
be actually relevant to what
they're doing right now.
So the next part is I
spoke about security.
And one of the
points-- so we've made
it easier for your end users.
And now we want to
talk about security.
And I think it's really
important in security
that security isn't
a static thing.
Security is always
a moving target.
And it's really,
really important
to stay ahead of the game.
And part of our job at
Google is to stay ahead
of the game in the
security landscape.
I like to show this infographic.
So this is from a website called
informationisbeautiful.net.
There's a public link.
I have it in my slides.
If anybody wants the slides, I
can share the link out later.
Or if you fill out that
form, and just ask me,
I'll send the link to you.
Now look at all
of these breaches.
And look at all of the users
that were impacted by that.
Some of these are in the
tens of millions of users
that were affected by a breach.
Some of these we might
be familiar with.
Probably the most
famous one recently
was the Ashley Madison
one where 36 million users
had very, very personal data
leaked onto the internet.
And then some banks, and
stores, and that kind of thing
where people had personal
information leaked out-- maybe
not onto the internet, like in
the case of the Ashley Madison
one.
But the overall picture
that people have
is that their data, their
personal details, their credit
card, other stuff
like that, is at risk
every single day from hackers.
Now a lot of this stuff,
of course, was inside jobs.
Some of the retail
ones where people
had planted a worm inside the
credit card scanning machines
that was able to collect
data about credit cards that
were scanned.
It's a little bit of
a different scenario
than you may be
facing when you're
building something for sign-in.
But the bottom line is to
users, it's all the same.
It's really, really a
feeling of insecurity
that people are out
there to get them.
And it's our job to
at least try to help
them feel a little bit
more secure when they're
using your apps,
when they're using
your sites, that kind of thing.
So you don't want
to be this guy.
And you want to help
them not to be this guy.
Sometimes I think I should
just change my passwords
and correct for this reason.
We really want to help
them not be this guy.
So the next part that I want
to talk about a little bit
is one of the biggest things
where your users are at risk,
and that's from phishing scams.
Now, there was
some research done
by the Canadian government.
And this research found that
156 million phishing emails
are sent out every single day.
Now, by the way, this research
was done a couple of years ago.
So I think these numbers
are probably bigger now.
So of those 156 million phishing
e-mails-- now of course,
we all have great
e-mail filters.
We all have great tools
that allow us to filter out,
and to stop phishing
scams, and to block them.
So how many of that
156 million do you
think got through these filters?
Anybody take a guess?
Did somebody say 10%?
That's a good guess.
16 million, around 10%,
actually got through.
So when you think
about this, a lot
of the free e-mail providers,
like Gmail, and Yahoo,
and Hotmail, et cetera, they
all provide these spam filters.
And I'm sure like
many of you, I've
gotten my name on all of them.
I'm lmoroney@yahoo,
@hotmail, @gmail,
and all these kind of things.
And these try their best to
keep spam and phishing away
from my eyes.
Some are better than others.
I won't say which are bad.
But most of them try to keep
phishing away from my eyes.
But some of them do get through.
But it's a little bit of
a side benefit, I think,
if you're using
something like a Gmail
because these services
receive the most phishing.
They're best at identifying
phishing-- much more than maybe
an independent server would be.
And as a result, if your users
are already using something
like Gmail, then
they're already being
less exposed to phishing
scams because less
are reaching their inbox.
I don't know about
you who use Gmail,
but I think when
I look at phishing
e-mails that are sent
to me, far less than 10%
get to my Gmail inbox.
All right.
So 16 million of the 156
million got through filters
to end users.
How many of those
16 million do you
think were actually
opened by the end users?
A quarter of a million?
OK.
It's higher than
quarter of a million.
Sorry?
25%?
OK, it's actually
higher than 25%.
I feel like a game
show here, right?
80%?
It's lower than 80%.
50%.
Thank you.
It's actually eight
million-- about half.
Now remember, this is every
single day users are opening--
and this was an older research.
I think it's
probably higher now.
Every single day,
users were found
to be opening eight
million phishing scams.
OK, next question.
Most phishing scams have
a link in them, right?
The typical phishing
scam is like, oh, I'm
from-- insert your
mail service here--
Your password has failed.
Please sign in here to
change your password.
That's the typical one.
So there's usually
a link that you
go to, to a fake website, where
they harvest your password.
So how many of
those eight million
do you think the people
actually clicked on the link
and went to the website?
A million.
OK, that's close enough.
It's 10%.
It's about 800,000.
So every single day, 800,000
of these links are clicked on.
And people are going to sites
with phishing scams on them.
All right.
You go to this site.
Now, a lot of the time you've
gone to this site-- and most
people in this room, I'm
sure, are smart enough
to look at the URL and see
that, hey look, this URL isn't
yahoo.com or google.com,
or wherever, Facebook,
or wherever.
It's bob.biz slash something.
And nowadays, browsers have
that like little green thing
that they put in the address
bar to show that this really
is certified, that this
is the correct site.
But 800,000 of these people
have gone to these sites.
How many of them do you
think were still fooled
and actually entered
their user data?
Half?
OK, thank God it's a
bit less than that.
It's still 10%.
It's about 80,000.
So per day, 80,000 people
fall for a phishing scam.
And many of those usernames
and passwords are compromised.
People might be using
the same username
and password on other sites.
Like I said, for me,
there is a phrase
that I know that
nobody else knows.
And most of my passwords
kind of root off
of that phrase by changing
letters around, or adding
numbers, or punctuation.
And it helps me to
remember passwords.
So had I gone to one of
these phishing sites,
and if any of phishers are
watching this live stream,
they now know that my password
has that kind of combination.
So maybe I need to change it.
But if they've gotten one of
these sources of my password,
then they already
have several steps
towards being able to compromise
my account in other places.
So it's a tough
landscape out there.
And it's up to us
as app developers
and as site developers to
protect our end users in that.
So as part of the
values that we try
to offer with Google Sign-In,
all of this kind of stuff
becomes possible.
So when you use a Gmail sign-in,
when you use a Google account,
I'm sure a lot of you, like
me, travel around-- maybe
around the country,
maybe around the world.
You've probably
encountered these things.
I was in England two weeks ago.
And when I tried to
sign in in England,
Google didn't challenge me.
I then the following
day went to Wales.
And when I tried to
sign in from Wales,
Google were like, this
is suspicious activity.
We're going to challenge
you for some extra details
just to make sure that you
really are moving around.
You've been in three
countries in three days.
What's really going on here?
And it was an extra
layer of security
that Google were able to provide
to protect my password in case
somebody really was
scamming me, somebody really
was taking that kind of thing.
Another tool that's
in there is being
able to sign out of
sessions remotely.
Now, one of the
things that's nice
is that if you use internet
cafes, or that kind of thing,
and you sign into your Gmail,
and you forget about it,
you can go, and you
can sign out remotely.
But it's also really
nice that, hey, you've
gotten this warning.
We've detected suspicious
activity on your account.
Somebody in Wales has tried
to sign into your account.
What's going on here?
You can then go and just
kick that person out remotely
before you change
your password details.
Things like that.
Unusual activity alerts--
same kind of thing.
If there's strange activity
going on, you get alerts.
You get alerts sent to you.
You can have alerts details
and all that texted to you,
and whatever.
There's some
intelligent challenges
on there for the same reason.
There's all of this
infrastructure designed
to protect your
username and password.
So if you were one of these
people who inadvertently gave
some details out
in a phishing scam,
you can find out right
away when your users,
or when you are using
a Google identity.
And then there's all
the infrastructure
that I mentioned behind
it, all the security
of the infrastructure.
One of the main places that
passwords get compromised
is that somewhere
in a system, they're
stored in a place
that's unencrypted.
Or maybe they're
passing from A to B
across an infrastructure
that's unencrypted.
And it's easy for somebody
to sniff that off a network.
And as a result, passwords
can be compromised.
Again, the infrastructure that's
behind Google's credential
system, behind our
ID system, hopefully
doesn't have any of that.
We haven't had any--
at least that I
know of right now-- any
major compromises or that
kind of thing.
So again, if your users
are using Google Identity,
if they're using any kind
of Sign-In with Google,
all of this backend
is there for them.
So enough about the user.
What about the developer story?
And I mentioned earlier on about
there were some difficulties.
And there were some bumps
in the road that you have
when you try to sign in.
So we've tried to
make it a lot easier.
And I'm going to talk through
some of the steps here.
I'm not going to demo it because
unfortunately, the emulator
doesn't yet run the version
of Google Play Services that
has this on it.
And it's just too awkward to
try and do it with a device
while I'm on stage.
So I'm just going to
demo by showing the code.
So first step-- instead
of connecting directly
to Google API Client, the API
has this thing called a Google
Sign-In Options Object.
Or we just call it
a GSO for short.
So your first task
is to create a GSO.
And in this case, I'm
doing a very simple one.
I'm not requesting any
additional permissions other
than the basic email identifier.
And thinking about just
the person's email address
as the thing that they
identify themselves with,
you saw that dialog
earlier with the pop-up
where it was like [INAUDIBLE]
and his email address.
That's what springs this.
And this doesn't require any
permissions from the user other
than just filling in
that account picker.
If you were, for example,
to access Google Drive,
or you wanted to access Google
Drive, or any other things,
there would be an additional
dot on here before the .build.
And then the user would get the
dialog saying, hey, you know,
this app also wants to access
to Google Drive, et cetera.
But if you're doing
this, and this
is the basic and the
most common case,
you're just going to have
those three steps that I
showed in the earlier slide.
Next now, if you have built
with Google Play Services,
and if you've built with
authentication and Identity
with Google Play
Services, you'll
know about the
Google API client.
And here's where you set
up the Google API client.
You create it with a builder.
And you access it with the @API.
And you pass it the
GSO that you just
created earlier on the
second parameter there.
It's off the Google Sign-In API.
And you just pass
it that GSO object.
And that GSO object
had the configurations
for the type of permissions
that you want to access.
So it's as simple as that.
The function to determine
if there's an auth class--
there's a constant on there.
And that constant is
the Google Sign-In API.
So now you've created a GSO.
You've created your
Google API client.
So the next thing to do
is to get a sign-in intent
from the API for this
Google API client.
And you can see it's here.
I just create intent--
.signin.Intent--
equals of the
Google Sign-In API.
I pass it the API clients.
Remember the API
client was configured
with the sign-in object.
And then I start an
activity for that result.
There's a constant
on the right hand
side there-- [? rcSignin. ?]
That's not part of the API.
Usually, if you're
building an application,
and you start an
activity, so that Android
can tell which activity
result is for which activity,
you just pass it an integer.
And it can be anything
that you want.
It's just up to you.
If you've got multiple
activities going on,
it's up to you to identify
them with your own constants.
So in this case, this
constant, [? rcSignin, ?]
I think we've made it.
There is a sample
that you can download
that I took this code from.
I think was like 7,001.
So when you get the
callback saying,
hey, we got a result
for activity 7,001,
you know that it's that one,
that it's the sign-in one.
But like I said, it can
be anything you like.
And then you can see
the callback here
where you catch the
activity results.
So you get your own
And then on the
activity results,
you have a request code.
Remember the request code that
I said that you passed in.
If it's that request
code that you created
for the sign-in activity,
then all you have to do
is create a Google
Sign-In result object.
And this is going to be the
result of the call to Google
Sign-In API, .getSignin
result from the intent.
And the intent passes you
back the data parameter
that you can see at the top.
So now you have your
sign-in results.
And this sign-in result
object gives you everything
that you need to know about the
sign-in, such as the account.
And the account is a Google
Sign-In account object.
And you get that using the
result .getSigninAccount,
as it suggests.
And then you can query that
account object for things
that the user has given you
permission to, including, hey,
has this user actually
signed in and out?
That kind of thing.
So now that you have
your accounts, now
you can personalize your
application for that end user.
And it's as simple as that.
And again, just to look at the
flow again, it looks like this.
The user clicks the
Connect with Google button.
They get given the picker,
which asks them which accounts
do they want to sign in with.
They pick that account.
And then they're taken
to your application.
And you can customize
your application
as you please for that user.
Like in this case,
we see we have
the user's name, and
a picture, and stuff
at the top for that user.
And as I mentioned
before, that if you're
doing additional
scopes-- for example,
the one I always like
to use is Drive--
that if your app is going
to access the user's Drive,
there'll be an additional
step in between the middle one
and the right one
there where the user
has to give permission to that.
So this is great.
But guess what.
This is all very nice for
authenticating on the device.
But what happens when you
want to extend beyond that?
And I like to give a story here.
Before I joined Google, I was
an independent application
developer.
I worked for a lot of startups,
building applications for them.
And there was one
startup that I worked
with that they had this really
interesting app for a very
unique audience.
And their audience
was people who
own pets who hire other people
to look after their pets
for them.
So part of this was
like, I have a dog.
I'll use my own dog.
My dog is called Bucky.
And if I, for example, work too
much, and I can't walk Bucky,
then I can hire somebody
to walk Bucky for me.
But how do I know that
that person has actually
walked my dog for me?
So the idea behind
this app was that I
would have this person
they've hired use this app.
So then as they're looking
after my dog during the day,
as they're walking the dog, it
would collect data around that.
It would collect data
of where they walked,
and all that kind of stuff.
It was an interesting
little concept.
But of course, in order
to be able to use this,
people needed to sign
up for this service.
They register that
I am who I am.
And here's my password
that I sign in.
And I add dog walkers
to my account.
And so first of all, we
hit the first barriers
that I was talking about earlier
on of yet another sign-up
that people had to do.
So we thought, OK,
let's add social.
Let's add Sign-In with Google.
Lets add sign in with Facebook.
Lets add sign in
with Yahoo, and sign
in with Microsoft, and all
these kind of things in the app.
So it makes it easier for
people to get into it.
So that was the first part,
and it was all very nice.
But then we had all this backend
data, the backend example
including the address
of the person who
owns the dog, the site
where the dog gets walked,
all this kind of stuff.
And it's like, OK, it's
not crazy sensitive data,
such as bank account
details, or other stuff that
has been leaked on the
internet in the recent past.
But it's potentially sensitive.
People know where I live.
Maybe I have a really
expensive breed of dog
that could be kidnapped.
Who knows?
So there is
sensitive data there.
So how do we secure
that backend data?
And it's all very nice that if
we had a Sign-In with Google
that gets people
into my application
locally on my device.
And I can customize it for them.
But what then if those
credentials get passed up
to my backend
server, and I start
needing to identify the
person on the backend server?
Now suddenly, you can have a
middleman coming in, and maybe
a middleman posting stuff
to my server, saying,
yes this is Laurence Moroney.
It's lmoroney@gmail.com.
Give me his details.
So we need to be really
careful about extending
our applications to handle that.
So here's an example.
Here's my app.
My app has signed in.
By the way, do you
love my diagrams?
I'm not the most artistic
person in the world.
So my app has a
Sign-In with Google.
Google has provided an
identity for my user.
And maybe I'm
keying that identity
off the user's email address.
I then pass that e-mail
address up to my server.
And what can happen is
the bad guys can say,
huh, I can pass an e-mail
to the server as well.
And then what happens?
If I pass the email
to the server as well,
the server might be
able to post back
to me some of the details
about this person.
That would be bad.
So part of the extensibility
of Sign-In with Google
that we've done is say, OK,
let's treat this a little bit
differently.
My application, as well as
being able to sign in and get
an identity from the
user, such as their email,
I can also get this token.
And this token says,
OK, lmoroney@gmail.com
has signed in.
He signed in at this time.
Here's some of the
metadata around that.
Here's how we're signing that.
Here's how we're encrypting
and securing that.
My app can pass that
token up to my server.
So now the server passes
that token to Google
and gets an ACK back
saying, yes, this is good.
Or this really is a
token that we issued.
This really is
lmoroney@gmail.com.
This isn't some kind of fake.
This is the person.
Now, how we can do
this-- there's two ways.
The way that we recommend is
we've got a set of libraries
that you can do this.
So those libraries do that
communication on your behalf.
And I have a few code
snippets I'll show
in a moment that show them.
But we also have an
endpoints that you can call.
Then you can just call that
endpoint and get the data back.
We recommend the
endpoint for debugging.
And it's all in the docs.
I have some links at
the end of the slide.
But we recommend the
libraries for production work.
So now if a bad guy comes
in, and the bad guy passes up
a fake token, of course
the usual security happens.
Your server can then try and
pass the fake token to Google.
And Google will come
back, and they go, uh-uh.
That's not going to happen.
And then you will
know So it just
secures your backend server
with your user's identity
from Google that much better.
So let's look a little
bit at the code for this.
Remember earlier
on, the first step
on your Android application
was creating the GSO.
Well, one of the things
I've just highlighted in red
here-- I've added
another method to this.
And this method
was requestIDToken.
And I passed this thing called
the server client ID in there.
And the server client ID
is this unique ID that's
generated for your server.
There are steps in
our documentation
that show you how to do that.
It's a big, long, ugly
string that you can just
put as a constant in your
app, or any other way
that you want to do it.
And so when you call
the requestIDToken,
now once the users
sign-in, once you've
got that successful
sign-in, you're
able to get that token, too.
So that's the only change
that you need to make.
So then step two-- when you're
setting up your Google API
client, spot the difference.
There is no difference.
It's exactly the same thing.
You don't need to change
anything in your code
for setting up the
Google API client.
Now, step three-- to
get the sign-in intent,
it's exactly the same.
We've added that one
line of code to the GSO,
but creating the
Google API clients,
calling the Google API
client, connecting it,
and getting the
sign-in intent back,
the flow is exactly the same.
But then once you get your
result back-- So earlier,
if you remember this one on our
activity results coming back,
if the activity was the
rcSignin activity, when
we get our result back, and
we get our account back,
there's a method on the account,
which is get the ID token.
So this gets the token for us.
We have this token
now in our client
upon a successful sign-in.
And it's a simple case
of posting that token
to the server, to
our own server.
When I say, "our,"
I don't mean Google.
I mean "our" if I'm the
application developer.
So my backend server is
an application developer.
Post the token to that.
And then that token
can be posted to Google
and authorized by
Google on your behalf.
So again, just looking at that
flow-- here, my application.
The user has signed
in with Google.
They've gotten the
identity token from that.
They post the token
to the server.
So now Google will
get the server,
ACK it, and send it back.
So we avoid the
bad guys doing it.
Let's see what the code
for that would look like.
Here's how you process
the code on your server.
Sorry I need to turn
around because I
can't read it on my laptop.
So first of all,
the ID token string
is that token that's come
from your Android client,
has been posted to the server
just as a string on an http
post, or hopefully in an https
post-- your secure post--
and you get your ID token.
So you want to just check.
If it's not null, now
you have this on the API.
This is not part
of the Android API.
This is part of the
libraries that I mentioned
that you can use on your
backend server, the Google
Libraries for authentication.
An object in there
is called-- surprise,
surprise-- a Google
ID token verifier.
The Google ID token
verifier is then
built just using a
couple of objects
to transport in the JsonFactory.
But the important thing is,
two things that you need to do.
Number one, you need
to set the audience.
Now, the audience can be a
number of different servers
because you may have
multiple servers posting
into this thing.
And you want the audience
for each of these.
In the scenario,
I just have one.
And the ID for that--
if you remember,
I was talking earlier
about the server client ID.
I know it sounds like an
oxymoron, a server client.
But it's the client ID from
your server to Google servers.
So you set the
audience with that ID.
And then you set the issuer.
And the issuers is just
accounts.google.com.
And then you build this thing.
And then after you
build this thing,
you can then just verify
your token by calling verify,
or .verify, that actual
string that was posted up.
And if that comes
back as not null,
then this token has a
payload associated with it.
All the things in orange
on the slide, by the way,
are part of the API.
So the payloads that you
create from that ID token
has something, for
example, a method in it,
which is the getSubject.
And that just gives
you the user ID.
So if you think about the
flow, the user on your device
tries to sign in.
When they sign in, Google
issue a token to your device.
Your device then gets that token
and posts it to your server.
Your server gets that token
and posts it back to Google.
Google then verify that
token, and come back and say,
this is the user ID
associated with that token.
So you have the complete flow
from your device to your server
securely for your
actual end user.
So then if you're building,
for example, a dog
walker application,
and you don't
want a nefarious third
party to access data
such as the breed of your
dog, or your address,
or where you live, this is
a great way of doing that.
So all of this data
that's in flight
is much more secure
than if it was
just an e-mail being
passed to your server
to identify the end user.
So that's really
part of the value.
And that's what Sign-In
with Google is all about.
And that's why we're working
so hard to make it the best
technology we possibly can.
So all of those above
scenarios that I spoke about
become possible.
Hopefully, you avoid your
users having the issues
that I spoke about earlier
on, where many of them
walk away if they forget their
password, and stuff like that.
There's a few resources
that I've put here.
So the main website
that we have,
developers.google.com/identify
has all of the background
information on this, as well
as some more complex scenarios.
There's one that I
haven't gone into here,
but to describe it briefly
was we spoke about your server
being able to access
Google's back end
to verify that a person
is who they say they are.
But what if-- using my
Drive scenario again--
if you've built it so that
you're requesting Drive
on the phone, and the
person is able to access
Drive on their phone,
that's all very well.
But what if you want
your server to access
Drive on their behalf?
Maybe instead of the dog walks
being saved on the phone,
you want to save them
to the user's drive,
and you want your server
to be able to do that?
Or something along those lines.
Again, there's a more complex
flow that you have to think
about because now you're having
your server talk to your end
users' identities
on their behalf,
accessing stuff which could be
sensitive in their Google Drive
on their behalf, et cetera.
And you want to make
sure that's secure.
I don't have all the details in
this talk to go through that.
But those kind of scenarios,
as well as the two that I
mentioned, are all on
developers.google.com/identity.
There's really, really
great sample code.
It's on GitHub under
googlesamples/googleservices.
And the sample code actually
has four scenarios in it.
The first scenario, simple
Sign-In that I've shown.
The second scenario of simple
Sign-In, but with Drive
on the device being shown.
The third scenario
of authenticating
against your backend
server that I've shown.
And in the fourth scenario,
that more complex one,
that we're saying
where your server may
need to also authenticate
against Google
services on your user's behalf.
That's also in that sample.
So it's pretty cool.
And then finally,
if you frequent
androiddevelopers.blogspot.com,
we actually
have an ongoing
series on Identity.
There's a post actually going
out today about all the server
scenarios that I mentioned.
So great resource.
Go take a look at that if
you're interested in anything
Identity.
And of course, reach out
to me or any of the team.
I gave a form at the
beginning of the talk.
And here it is again.
So [? j.mp/offeedback. ?]
And with that,
I'd just like to say thank you
for coming and spending some
time with us.
[APPLAUSE]
I have three minutes
for questions.
We have one here.
Yep, in the center here.
Oh, waiting for a mic.
AUDIENCE: Some
applications might have
some sort of age restriction.
So is there any way
to check for age,
or if they haven't already
put their age in their Google
account, ask them to provide it?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's a good question.
Is there an access on the
ID object for their age?
This is Paul from
the Identity team.
PAUL: Hi, guys.
So basically, what
it sounds like is
you need actually additional
information that we
don't provide.
So we don't provide specific
ages and things in Profile.
So actually, once they've
signed up with a Google account,
I would then ask some
additional questions
to build out their profile.
So it saves you asking for
username, and password,
and everything.
But then the rest of the
information you might need,
you would request at that
point in your sign-up flow.
By that point, they've
already got a login.
So you could
potentially delay it to
later on if you don't
need that age immediately.
You may have seen
LinkedIn and other sort
of social network
sites ask, hey,
your profile isn't
100% complete.
Maybe you can add this
information later on,
and encourage them to do so
with benefits and things.
But that's typically how
we see it [? done. ?] OK?
There may also be age
restrictions on how young
you can be to have
a Google account.
I don't know off
the top of my head.
But if you post a question
to that, we can confirm that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Over here.
AUDIENCE: Does the new flow
request any permission?
Like in the old flow, you
required this getContact
or the [INAUDIBLE] permission?
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it
will request permissions
in a number of
scenarios, like if there
are things that you're
requesting that need
that additional permission.
I used Drive as an example.
But if you're just saying
that .requestEmail on the GSO,
then there's no further
permissions required.
PAUL: So sorry,
just to add to that.
Are you talking about
Android permissions or user
Permissions?
So like with Android
M specifically,
the great thing about
this new library
is that it actually removes
any getAccounts permission.
So there's no sort of
system dialogue permissions
you need to request now
to use Google Sign-In.
And so that's actually one
of the beauties of updating
to the latest
version of the API,
is that you can remove
that whole step.
That was one of the
steps that was actually
in that horrific slide
with thousands of steps.
So as far as that's
concerned, under Permissions,
no permission is requested
from the user, like contacts,
or camera, or
anything like that.
There's just the
permissions you're
asking for the services
you're trying to use.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you
LAURENCE MORONEY: I've
only time for one more.
Maybe at the front here.
So any other
questions, please just
fill them out on this form,
and we'll get back to you.
AUDIENCE: Quick question--
the Google Drive and YouTube
authentication,
that's just going
to work with this as well?
So if we want to
post from the app
to YouTube or
access Google Drive,
do we need to do anything extra?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So of course, there
will be Drive APIs for
accessing Drive itself.
You'll need to do that.
This is just the
permissions layer
to give you access to that.
AUDIENCE: But
authentication-- once I
do this, it should
just still work, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, so for example,
if you've got multiple accounts
on your phone, as many of us
do, then there's
multiple ways into Drive.
And there's multiple
access points on Drive.
So if your application
provides the identity
to Drive that you've
signed in with,
it will be that Drive account
that you're able to access.
PAUL: The new Sign-In
account has just
replaced the sign-in
that used to happen
on Connect and everything.
This now, you'll
notice that it's still
feeding back into the
same Google API client.
So that still functions
in the same sort of way.
So this is all about
the process that
happens in the sort of
startup with the API client,
and Connect, and
all the rest of it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: All right.
Thanks everybody.
And again any questions, just
fill them out on that form.
It's [? j.mp/offeedback. ?]
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]